ever since I was a child people said my
family was
cursed mom tried to protect us with
God pop tried to protect us with
wrestling he said if we were the
toughest the strongest nothing could
ever hurt
us I believed him we all
did morning pants tomorrow please
David Harry I want you to join your
brothers in the ring yes sir I love that
now we all know Carrie's my favorite
then Kev then David then Mike but the
rankings can always change what do you
want in life Kevin Eric more ribs I want
to be with my
family you know be with my
brothers what do you like to do with
your
brothers Adam har and
[Music]
David
you together we can do
anything we're here to restore Justice
to the Wrestling Federation that our
father built with his own two hands the
hands that will passed down to us the
hands that will deliver the iron claw to
you so what do you think like we're a
alive I love your family
Kevin going to be an uncle yes sir oh
man that makes me so happy I talk to you
about something m d too tough on must
you got to say something babbe that's
what your brother's are for you feel
that you feel that that's
pressure you're pushing too hard I'm
fine K seriously I'm just
sick God I'm scared man all my out of
control was a terrible accident I should
have stopped him I need to think about
my family your job is to wrestle live up
to that deal where we are
through I told to them look out for
I just love being out there with you
guys it's the only thing that matters to
me the will forever be the greatest
family in the history of
[Applause]
[Music]
wrestling